[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section let me
hear from you there you might think that
you know everything about your own body
but there are still a lot of things that
will surprise you and you will also
discover that you have some super powers
if this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you five things you
didn't know about the human body baby
bones do you know how many bones we have
in our body many of us are not even able
to name ten and we think that we might
have around 50 but the human adult has
206 bones in their body and what
surprises us the most is that babies
actually have about 300 different bones
and cartilage elements in their body
what happened to them we don't
understand how about 100 bones would
just randomly disappear when we grow up
but these bones are still in our body
they just fuse together for example at
Birth the cranium has three unfused
plates that are soft and flexible they
need to be pliable and overlap each
other to allow the baby's head to go
through the birth canal between 6 and 18
months these plates will fuse into one
piece moreover all bones start off as
cartilage they start developing during
the second trimester and some of them
are not ready yet when the baby is born
at that time they are still flexible
which allows them to be less prone to
breaks these body parts are alive and
they will grow and change just like the
rest of the body over time the cartilage
fuses together through a process called
ossification it is only by 25 years old
that the entire bone development process
will be complete and that's just one
example of how amazing the human body is
hiccups all of us experienced hiccups
many times during our lives and most of
us don't even know what's happening in
our body when we're making these weird
noises at least we are happy that we are
not unlucky like Charles Osborne who
started hiccuping in 1922 and it only
stopped in 1990 that's a total of 68
years but what is the cause of this
weird phenomenon it is actually a sudden
involuntary contraction of the diaphragm
that occurs at the same time as a
contraction of the larynx and a total
closure of the glottis blocking air in
hey if you're wondering what a glottis
is it is the middle part of the larynx
where the vocal cords are located this
is like not having the control of our
lungs for a moment which is medically
known as SDF or synchronous
diaphragmatic flutter experts still
don't really understand why hiccups
occur as they can appear out of nowhere
for no apparent reason
usually they resolve after a few minutes
without any treatment but if it lasts
longer than a month the hiccups are
termed intractable and they can become a
serious medical problem that requires
treatment there are different things you
can try to control your diaphragm like
being surprised stop breathing or
thinking about something else but in
most cases it's just a way to pass time
as the hiccups disappear by itself
regeneration some of you have probably
heard that the human body replaces
itself every seven years according to
this idea we become a whole new person
because every cell in our body has been
replaced by a new cell it makes us feel
like a really slow Wolverine but is it
actually true there are between 50 and
75 trillion cells in the human body each
of them has a different lifespan before
they're replaced by another cell this is
why even when you pass away it may take
hours or even days before every cell in
your body ends its life - but how long
do they last when we're alive : cells
only last for days skin cells live about
2 or 3 weeks
red blood cells live for about 4 months
and white blood cells live on average
more than a year but there are some
things that will never change like your
brain cells which typically last an
entire lifetime the liver is amazing and
had the ability to grow back if part of
it is removed the tips of injured
fingers and toes can also grow back
under certain conditions but will we
ever be able to grow back a whole body
part only the future will tell us what
we will have the chance to do with
medicine and new technologies but for
now try to make sure that you don't lose
an arm saliva if you don't like to share
a glass of water or utensils with
someone you're probably disgusted by any
saliva that is not yours and with these
juicy facts we think that you'll also
start being disgusted by your own saliva
you might feel like there is not a lot
of saliva in your mouth but your
salivary glands actually produce 2 to 6
cups of saliva every day if you produce
6 cups it will come close to filling a
2-liter soda bottle just make sure that
no one drinks it if you try this kind of
experiment but saliva can also do
amazing
things it is used to discover secrets
from the past and know more about the
world we live in for example you could
use your saliva to know who your
ancestors were and where they come from
saliva could even save lives most people
don't want to do a blood test because
it's complicated it requires a visit to
the clinic and many people are afraid of
needles but with the spit screening
people could learn about factors that
increase their risk of cardiac arrest
and change their habits and someone
else's saliva could also be good for you
when two people kiss testosterone is
transferred into the woman's mouth and
this is what makes her fall in love more
easily now this is one good reason to
kiss your soulmate even more skin we
have learned that our body can replace
itself but we still have a lot of things
to say about our biggest organ the skin
it is protective waterproof and
incredibly useful which makes it one of
the most important parts of our body it
is composed of several layers and the
new skin cells gradually push their way
to the top layer when they reach the top
they die and they have to face our
environment and our daily activities
one day they break away from the
epidermis and fall off to make room for
the newest cells growing just below them
in total it can take up to a month for
the new cells to make their way to the
top and this phenomenon is more
impressive than you would have thought
skin makes up about 16% of our body
weight which is equivalent to roughly
one point six trillion skin cells every
hour between 30,000 and 40,000 of these
cells fall this is how we lose almost a
million skin cells every day which makes
up to four kilograms of skin every year
if you're wondering where it goes you
can find it all around your home as this
is what dust is mostly made of are there
any other things that you know about the
human body don't be shy to tell us what
it is in the comment section down below
we love to hear what you think and
that's it for 5 things you didn't know
about the human body if you want to see
more stories like this make sure you
watch fifteen ways the Internet has
changed your life thanks for watching
[Music]